[Music]
all right now we're ready to start
migrating virtual machines to google
cloud vmware engine
hi my name is raj shetnani with google
cloud and now we're going to start
looking at how to extend our network
from our on-prem environment to google
cloud in order to perform a live vmotion
with zero downtime between an
on-premises environment and the cloud to
begin we're going to go back to our
on-prem htx environment select network
extension under services and we're going
to select a port group that's been vlan
tagged for us to stretch between on-prem
and the google cloud side this is done
with a pair of the network extension
appliances that get deployed as part of
your service mesh so first thing we're
going to see here is the ability to
select the destination
network as well as optionally enabling
mobility optimized networking which
comes in handy if you're stretching
multiple networks and you want the vms
on those networks to be able to
communicate to one another without
tromboning back on prem
go ahead and put in the gateway and as
you can see here we already selected our
destination router and we'll go ahead
and submit
this will take a few minutes to complete
and as mentioned before this leverages a
pair of network extension appliances
in general you don't want to stretch
networks over a long period of time
but for the purposes of migration it
allows us to go ahead and migrate vms
with that zero downtime capability and
in a future date you can swing the
gateway from your on-prem environment to
the cloud
next we're gonna go to the migrate
screen and actually perform the
migration if you ever need to do a
reverse migration moving from the cloud
back on-prem you can select reverse
migration here in order to populate the
opposite inventory
for now we're going to select server 1
which exists on-prem
add that to our list
and go ahead and start configuring where
we want this virtual machine to go by
selecting the compute container in this
case we're selecting a workload resource
pool
the data store in this case our vsan
datastore
and then the migration profile or how we
want to migrate the vm
in this case we'll go ahead and select
vmotion
put it in a specific folder
and from there you have also the option
to change the disk type format whether
it's thin or thick provision
additional options around the switchover
itself
as well as when you'd like the failover
window to take place
so the seed replication can occur
while the switchover can be defined at a
later time let's go ahead and click
validate and once that's complete we'll
go ahead and hit go and start the
migration
because we haven't defined when the
switchover occurs it'll occur as soon as
the initial data has been copied over
between the on-premises environment and
gcbe
now depending on the migration type that
you've selected
the distance that the vm needs to
traverse in order to transfer the data
latency
connection speed
how many service meshes and how many
parallel actions are occurring you'll
see different results based on that
it's a good idea to review the network
underlay characterization in h6
performance outcomes guide especially
when it comes to large-scale migration
environments or use cases now i have a
running ping going on in the background
during the v-motion switchover window
and in most on-premises environment when
a vmv motions between hosts you'll lose
maybe around one ping during that time
period we're gonna see if we see the
same thing here
and in fact as i cancel this out you can
see that at most we did lose one ping
during the switchover and the vm
continues to be accessible reachable
even migrating over
large distances
or large vms
and now let's take a look at the migrate
wizard once more
and make sure that the vm that we did
migrate is in fact no longer showing up
in our on-premises inventory
and is reachable and available
on the google cloud vmware engine site
and as you can see server one has been
removed from the list
awesome congratulations you've just
completed the video series around hcx
migration and just migrated your first
virtual machine from your on-premises
environment to the cloud with zero
downtime
for more tips and tricks check out the
rest of the videos in the series and
thanks for watching to learn more about
google cloud vmware engine visit our
site at cloud.google.com
vmware dash engine
[Music]
you